right yeah yeah yeah we see them
fantastic
okay cool uh welcome back everyone so
next we have li yang tan
from stanford university who is going to
tell us about testing and reconstruction
via decision trees uh thanks a lot uh
thanks for the
opportunity to speak very happy to see
so many friendly names
in the audience um i'm gonna talk about
joint work with guy blank and jane lang
students at stanford and mit
uh two things one is the slides and also
the paper
they are available on my web page so if
you prefer to you know scroll
scroll around as i speak uh you can go
to my webpage and the second thing is
please interrupt me with questions that
will make it a lot more
fun for me i did a practice run
yesterday and i i went five minutes over
time
so i i think we have a 45 minute slot i
cut out a section and now we are at 40
minutes so i'm five minutes under time
so i think we should be able to go at a
very relaxed pace
okay yeah please ask questions okay good
um
so let's get started so this is about
testing and reconstruction
these are two tasks that are closely
related to learning so let me i thought
i'll start by talking about decision
tree learning
uh this is a very well studied and basic
problem we're given labeled data
x y pairs and our goal is to to generate
a decision tree that represents this
data
or as we like to think about it in
learning theory the function
that labels the data so this is an
extremely basic
and well-studied algorithmic task
okay uh and decision trees are going to
be the star of this talk so i'll spend
one more slide on uh just talking about
them they're one of the most
popular models in machine learning and
that popularity really stems from
their simplicity they you know they have
this really simple easy to understand
structure
they are fast to evaluate to figure out
how a decision tree
labels and input we simply follow the
relevant path
uh down the tree and the number of
variables we have to look at
is the length of the path and this is
often much smaller than
than the dimension of the problem as i
mentioned they have this like flowchart
like structure they're easy to
understand
and relatedly they're also very it's
also very easy to explain the
predictions of a decision tree model
why do you label this input 0 well x7
was 1
x11 was 0 and two was one that's why i
labeled it zero
decision trees are really one of the
canonical examples of an interpretable
function class algorithms for for
learning decision entries from labeled
data they're some of the most classic
algorithms in
machine learning and they continue to be
widely employed
and they perform very well in practice
okay
so that's decision trees and decision
tree learning this talk is not directly
about decision trees
learning it's about testing and
reconstructing decision trees
these are two tasks uh both of which are
easier
than learning how to be formal they're
no harder than learning
uh as we'll see in this talk well we're
gonna focus on on decision trees
and we'll draw on recent techniques from
learning decision trees to test
and reconstruct them and our results for
testing and reconstruction they have new
implications
for learning theory for learning
decision trees
so in fact one of the things i hope to
convince you of in this
talk is that although testing
reconstruction and learning
these are three algorithmic tasks they
can study for any function class
in this talk we're going to focus on
decision trees this web of connections
among
these three basic tasks they're
surprisingly rich
uh many of these implications and
connections
they're not known for other function
classes and that this talk will
will establish them by leveraging the
specific structure
of decision trees and hopefully in just
in the next few slides
when i start to describe my results our
results i will see some of these
surprising connections come in
okay so let's get started this is a
testing and learning workshop so i think
a lot of us all of us know what testing
is
um let me start with reconstruction i
myself i wasn't
too familiar with this notion before i
started working on this project
i like to think of reconstruction as
on-the-fly learning
so let me try to explain that point of
view so we are given query access to an
unknown function f
just like learning and we're promised to
that f is close to a small decision tree
just like learning uh so there's a
picture we have in
we have in mind and in traditional
learning and
this talk when i say learning i always
mean proper learning
in the case of decision trees i like to
upload a decision tree hypothesis
in traditional learning we like to
construct a decision tree hypothesis
call it t
right then we like t to be of size not
so much larger than
s and we like t to still be somewhat
close to f
maybe around opt or plus epsilon
so that's traditional proper learning
what is on-the-fly learning
well it's very simple you do not have to
compute
construct t but you just have to support
queries to teach so if someone else
comes along
and they give us x we should be able to
respond with t of x
to them they come with x prime we
respond with g of x
prime and always consistently with a
specific decision tree hypothesis t
right away we see that reconstruction is
no harder than learning
if we constructed the entire decision
tree hypothesis t
we can certainly support queries to t
the name of the game here is to do
things faster and more query efficiently
than constructing the entire decision
tree hypothesis
and so can you support queries to your
hypothesis without actually constructing
the hypothesis okay so that's
reconstruction
and with that i can state our main
result
which is a new reconstruction algorithm
for decision trees
so here's our result we are given query
access
to an unknown function f it's promised
to be
up close to a size s decision tree so
we're also given s as a parameter so we
know what s is
so this is a picture that we have in our
minds
we support queries to a decision tree
hypothesis t
of size s to the quasi polynomial in s
not too much larger than s
and t itself is still somewhat close to
f it's at most order or plus epsilon
close to f
we do not construct this t that would be
learning
however we are able to support queries
to t
where every query is answered
efficiently so if someone else comes
with
comes to us with x we can respond with t
of x
x prime t of x prime so and so forth and
every
x that comes to us we have to interact
with f
uh with poly log s log n many queries
and to ask f a single query that
requires
sort of like preparing an n bit string
so we incur an overhead of
necessary overhead of n in a runtime so
our runtime is simply
poly log s times n log n
so that's our main result uh any
questions
so this is what we get for on the fly
learning so
certainly this is only interesting if
it's better than
not on flight learning so let me compare
this with what is known or what's
possible for learning itself
traditional learning so we have our
result on the right where we can respond
without
constructing t we can respond to queries
uh quite efficiently poly log s times
log n many queries
now what is known for learning well
information theoretically um even for
non-proper learning
and even for the realizable setting
we're up to zero so this
much simpler than the setting depicted
on the left
uh it's not too hard to see that you
need omega s many queries
and again since to make a single query
you need to
prepare an n bit string and send it to f
you need omega s times
n time so here comparing you know our
result on the right
and this easy fact on the left we see
that we're getting
an exponential improvement over the
information theoretic minimum
required to learn so this is one of the
advantages of on-the-fly learning
we do not construct t however we are
able to support
queries to t with query and time
efficiency
that is quite a bit more efficient than
what is
possible for learning
and just a classification question so
the size
of the tree that is consistent with all
the answers
is s to the one over epsilon squared
that's what you said right
oh as to the largest i i wish it was n
to the one over epsilon squared this
quasi polynomial in s
even for fixed epsilon is called s the
log s square
yeah and so okay
yeah so there's room for improvement
although i'll talk more about it um
even for just yeah that it'll be nice to
bring the size down
it'll also be nice to bring this order
up plus epsilon down to one times r plus
epsilon
and i guess in the number of queries do
you also have a one over epsilon squared
then thank you yes i'm hiding the
dependence thank you i'm hiding the
dependence
on epsilon in the quarian time
complexity it's poly one of epsilon
everywhere
and i imagine for learning it's a little
bit different
the dependency on epsilon no i think or
it's one over epsilon squared for the
number of queries also
yeah okay cool thank you
so how do you measure distance uh you
know what is
up test and what metric do you compute
this
uniform discussion i've mentioned this
uniform distribution throughout the talk
and i'll only apply to the uniform
distribution
all right thanks yeah yeah it'd be very
interesting
um i think you know it's everything will
go through for practice
product distributions but but certainly
not for non-products
while we don't have any results for
non-product distributions and i'll find
it very interesting to get something for
general distributions
thank you uh yeah please ask more
questions
okay uh good so that's our result for
reconstruction
and as a consequence we get a new tester
for decision trees our reconstruction
algorithm to our knowledge is the first
reconstruction algorithm for
distributors
and from it we got a new tester but
testing decision chief has been
extremely well studied so i'm going to
state our results and i'm going to
compare it with with what's known for
testing decision trees
so it's here's the setup we're given
query access to an unknown function f
this parameter s we talk to f for a bit
and we output yes
if f is epsilon close to a size s
decision tree
and then we output no if f is epsilon r
or omega epsilon r
from a quasi quasi-polynomial size
design tree it's the same quasi
polynomial size
as the one we saw in the previous slide
okay so you know this
as we all know testing allows us to get
a ballpark sense as to
how big you know the decision tree for f
is
and you know the same kind of query and
time complexity comes up we can do this
in poly log s times log n queries
and again just to ask a single query we
need a factor of n
so the overhead and runtime is poly log
s times
n log n okay
so that's our tester
and again everything with respect to the
uniform distribution
so as i mentioned our reconstruction
algorithm as far as we know it's the
first but
this testing is we're not certainly not
giving the first tester for decision
trees it
has been very well studied and in
testing decision trees
and i'll work as do a long line of work
on testing discipline trees
so in the next slide i'd like to compare
our new tester with what's known
the long story short is that it's
incomparable but i'd like to spend a
slight telling you
how it's incomparable so here's our
tester
in pictures on the top so here are the
existing testers
uh the the sort of the one that achieved
the achieve the best parameters
you learn on on a line of work uh was
given by prosciutto just this year
so let's not worry about the query and
time complexity of this tester yet will
come to that
but even just the setup of the problem
is different
um these testers they say yes if f is
exactly a scientist
decision tree and they say no if f is
epsilon far from the size and string
tree
so sort of our except condition is more
stringent we have to say yes
as long as f is epsilon close to size s
decision tree
whereas they only have to say yes if f
is exactly a size
s decision tree so that makes our job
more challenging
on the other hand just to balance that
out their reject condition is more
stringent they have to say no as long as
f is epsilon far from size
s this increase whereas we only have to
say no if f is epsilon bar from a quasi
or normal size
decision tree so uh so they're
incomparable in the language of property
testing
we get a tolerant tester
which is more challenging whereas they
deal with sort of like the single
criteria testing
which is more challenging whereas we do
this you know by criteria or you know
parameterized testing
so there's just a setup itself is
incomparable
so let's compare our quarry complexity
and time complexity
uh there we look we we compared quite
favorably
the bashudis tester requires
linear or slightly super linear in fact
in as many queries
and again just to make it and their
runtime is actually quite a bit
worse than s comes in uh their runtime
is
s to the s times n so exponential in s
so our complexity and runtime compare
quite favorably with
with this existing testers we we
are getting a exponential improvement in
query complexity from s versus plotting
log s
and runtime we're even getting a doubly
exponential improvement in the
dependence on s
okay so that's the that's how our tester
compares with the existing testers
you could still ask as we did looking at
the right hand side of this picture
well what if could we improve our tester
to like being retaining tolerance and
making it single criteria
right that will make our result our
setup strictly
more challenging than that of the
existing testers
so can we strengthen our tester so that
we do not deal in this you know
parametric setting and strengthen this
to reject as long as
f is epsilon r from size s so again if
we are able to do this that'll be quite
satisfying
that will make our tester all set up
strictly more challenging quite a bit
more challenging than
than existing testers so that brings me
to our final result
we do not give such a tester but we come
full circle
and connected back to learning so we
show that
if we are able to do such improvement
then we get quite a new striking result
in learning
we get a fully polynomial time algorithm
for proper learning of
decision trees this is quite a
well-known open problem and this will be
quite a breakthrough so
the statement again is suppose we can
get a tester that is tolerant
and in this single criteria s versus s
setting
but quite a set a standard you know
question if we're able to get such a
tester then we get
a fully polynomial time algorithm for
proper learning of success decision
trees
and the the runtime of the the
current best algorithm for for proper
learning of decision trees it's a
classic result of aaron foreign house
very much in
quasi polynomial time so any improvement
on it will be exciting
certainly bringing it down to fully
polynomial time will be extremely
exciting
some may even think it's impossible
okay and leon quick question
yes the learning algorithm here would be
with membership queries
or yes with
but it would still be a breakthrough
because of being proper absolutely
yeah okay thanks everything is proper
yeah thanks
so as rocco mentioned if we are
interested in non-proper learning then
we do have such a
such a fully polynomial time algorithm
thanks to push levitz in my store
yeah thanks marco yeah in this talk i
just mean i always mean proper learning
i like the output the decision tree
okay uh and just one you know sort of
a non-technical note i guess uh
the direction you know the fact that if
you have a proper learning algorithm you
get a testing
algorithm this is standard and not too
hard to see
so this is also the fact that testing
itself is no harder than proper learning
this box our result gives an example of
the converse
that a testing algorithm gives a proper
learning algorithm for the same class
so um which i find quite interesting i'm
not aware of
having us rocco also about this i i'm
not aware of
previous examples of such an implication
although i'll love it if someone could
correct me um
but anyway for decision trees we now
have such a connection
they have you know a good enough tester
you actually can learn
okay so that actually that's all of our
main results
but i would like to tell you about some
consequences of our results not for
decision trees
so decision trees are uh basic of
technologists and learning and machine
learning but
you know they they also hold a special
place in the hearts of
complexity theorists they one reason is
this injury complexity is closely
related quantitatively to many other
measures of viewing function complexity
uh the fourier degree approximate degree
randomized query complexity
sensitivity so and so forth the study of
these quantitative relationships is a
field of query complexity very active
many exciting developments recently and
thanks to these
relationships our results for decision
trees
immediately give us new reconstructors
and new testers
for all these properties and the sort of
the landscape is the same for these
properties
we give the first three constructors for
these properties
and they in turn build testers but test
in terms of testing you know for many of
these properties
uh testing for these properties has been
extremely well studied
so good i was thinking i would just list
one of such
one such consequence for great degree
giving a reconstructor
for fourier degree so
here's what we have so first of all this
fact from query complexity this is not
due to us this is
this is you know well-known so for every
boolean function f
um the fourier degree the degree of f
that's the polynomial of the reals
is no larger than its decision tree
depth that's easy to see
what is surprising and cool is the fact
that the decision tree depth
is also upper bounded by a polynomial of
a polynomial factor of the fourier
degree
so using this fact that you know
decision tree depth is sandwiched by
degree
we can combine it with our decision tree
reconstructor and get a reconstructor
for
for a degree low degree polynomials
so here's the statement i think maybe
you can all guess what it's going to say
but given query access to an unknown
function f it's promised to be close
to a low degree boolean
function we support queries
to a polynomial q
of degree not too much larger than that
of p into the seventh
that is still close to f and most order
of plus epsilon
and every query to q is
answered efficiently if you come to me
with x i can respond
q of x without constructing x itself
without constructing
q itself and every query i can respond
by only
making probably d times log n many
queries to f
and you know run time with a factor of n
over here
so that's our reconstructor for the
fourier degree it follows
as an immediate consequence of of our
decision tree reconstructor
and to me this is really a testament to
the imaging of query complexity
right looking at this this result i
wouldn't have thought to go through
decision trees
it's you know seems like there's more of
an analytics feel to it
uh but thanks to this fact at the top of
this page
uh there's really it's really in some
sense equivalent to constructing
decision trees
okay so here's the outline for the rest
of this talk i was
i really want to tell you about the key
structural result that underlies
the algorithmic consequences that i just
talked about and i'd like to show you
most of its proof
the next bullet is what i cut out uh i
was going to tell you about
how our reconstruction algorithm follows
as a consequence of this structural
result
i don't have time for that um but it's
like on my web page
so i was thinking i'll skip this next
bullet and i'll close the talk
by talking about some further everything
for future work
um yeah the structural result is this
works out well the structural result
is what i'm most excited about and i
think there could be applications beyond
just learning and testing and
reconstruction
so i'd like to tell you about uh this
structural result and it's proven
okay leon if your quick question if um
if you're looking at real value decision
trees and your loss is square loss
do your results also hold for that
setting thanks adam you mean the output
of the input
the outputs are real valued yeah i
suspect our
we do not we do not write this in a
paper i suspect our results also go
through for for real value
and for for their uh sort of like square
loss
yeah but i yeah um maybe let's yeah
maybe i can
follow up on this i'm pretty sure it
does okay thanks
uh okay uh so here's the key structural
result
um in a nutshell uh this is not gonna be
formal but
the spirit of it is as follows suppose
you tell me f
is close to a small distance f is up
close to a size s decision tree
okay here's the picture i've in mind
well but you know i really have no idea
what this tree looks like
why should i you know there could be
multiple such trees first of all
i have no idea what the internal nodes
look like i have no idea what this
leaves look like
right however our structural result says
that f is
r plus epsilon order or plus epsilon
close to a
tree t um the purple tree of size
quite a bit bigger than s
quasi-polynomial s
so it's slightly bigger and its distance
f has grown a little bit
which is not ideal night of which is
ideal but in exchange for that
this tree in purple has a very specific
structure and has many enjoyable
properties
i can describe exactly to you what each
of its internal nodes are
i can tell you exactly what its needs
are and make that
formal in a second and our algorithms
for reconstruction and testing
will leverage the structure and these
properties okay so
the bulk of the talk will be devoted to
telling you about this
purple tree
okay so let me just tell you about
all the properties in structural history
the two of which we've already seen one
is that it's
r plus epsilon order or plus epsilon
close to s
the second is that the size is as the
longest squared
well those are i guess the properties of
the tree
now i have to tell you i have to fill in
this like blank triangle i have to tell
you about the structure
of the stream for every internal node
of the tree let's call the path that
leads to the internal node
chi i can tell you exactly what the
variable query
at this internal node is it's going to
be x i where x i
is the variable with the largest noisy
influence
on the sub function f sub i so the next
few slides i'll tell you what
i mean by noisy influence but now let me
just mention that there's some measure
of the importance of a variable
so that's going to be my notion of
importance and at every node
i'm going to query the variable that i
find the most important
here is denoted x9
and for the leaves we do the most
natural thing possible
um for every leaf l i will label l
with the the zero one bit it corresponds
to the bias of that
sub l the sub function there's more bias
towards one i plonk down the one leaf
if it's more biased to zero i plonk down
the zero leaf the most natural thing
possible
so really it's sort of like the the the
the smarts come in in three deciding
what to split on
and that's gonna be the the focus of
next few slides
okay so what's this notion of noisy
influence
as i mentioned it assigns to every
variable
a number that denotes how important it
is and i'm going to split on
the the variable that is most important
according to this measure
so to tell you about noisy influence i
have to first tell you about noise
sensitivity
the noise sensitivity of a function
f at noise rate delta is
this probability you draw x uniformly at
random
and you draw a delta noisy copy y and
you
tell me the probability that f of x
differs from y and the delta noisy copy
is simply what you get by re-randomizing
every coordinate with probability delta
or equivalently since we're working over
a uniform distribution
by flipping every coordinate with
probability delta over two
so you know i start at a uniform random
point x in a hypercube
i take a little random walk i like to
know whether i walk
you know from f of x equals one to f of
x equals zero or vice versa
so there's some measure of the
complexity of the function
and that's noise sensitivity what's the
noisy influence of a variable
noisy influence of the variable i on f
is what the drop in noise sensitivity
when xl is query that's how i like to
think about it
this is it in math it's drop
in noise sensitivity
when you know xl is originally
the larger the drop the higher the noisy
influence
and to me the higher the noisy influence
the more important i find this verb
so my tree is going to be built by
at every node i query the variable
that results in the largest drop in
noise
sensitivity the variable of highest
noisy influence
okay so that's sort of like i guess
you'll call this a splitting criteria
of my decision tree let me actually this
may seem like it came out of nowhere why
this notion of importance
um so i like to put it in context a
little bit so
this this the context of this is in the
splitting criteria of just disciplinary
learning heuristics for building
decision trees in this like top-down
manner
and it really builds off of it of real
world heuristics
like id3 card which some of you may be
familiar with they split on not the
variable x i not with the largest
noisy influence but the largest
correlation with
with the with the sub function
and noisy influence came out of some
work we did trying to understand these
heuristics
and roughly speaking noisy influence can
be viewed as the higher order
a higher order generalization of
correlation unfortunately i do not have
time to elaborate on what this means
but you know there are so many experts
in the audience
the correlation of a variable with a
function is simply it's linear for a
coefficient since we're working over the
uniform distribution
and noisy influence is just a notion of
correlation that takes it not
takes into account not just the linear
coefficient but you know the
the higher order fluid coefficients as
well and this this
this generalization is necessary for
structural theorem it's not
too hard to see that any such structure
theorem is impossible it's just straight
up false
for correlation if you use correlation
as a splitting criteria
instead of noisy influence so that's how
we came up with this notion of noisy
influence as the splitting criteria it
builds quite naturally off of what they
use in the real world
to build decision trees and all of this
sort of comes out from
some work we have been doing trying to
understand these real world heuristics
and trying to give
guarantees on it we realize that some of
the techniques we developed there
has have applications back in theory so
this is
this this project was born out of that
okay so that's sort of a side about why
we
we go with noisy influence as our
splitting criteria
let's go back to our structural result
here we state it
so let us be any function
is off close to some decision tree or
size s consider the tree t
of size s to the log s squared defined
as follows
for every path time leading to an
internal node
query the variable with the largest
noisy influence
on f sub pi
and for every leaf simply plonk down the
zero one value that's the most natural
just
round f sub l uh according to its
expectation and the claim is that if you
build this tree
then it's going to be for any f it's
going to be order of plus epsilon close
to f
okay so i think i'll spend my remaining
time
proving this structural result let's
dive in
so here well i've not done anything here
here's just you know f is up close the
side says the gene tree this this
entry is on our right um and my claim
is that the distance with respect to the
uniform distribution from t to f
is order of plus epsilon so how are we
going to prove this
well we think of t as being built
layer by layer by layer so i define t1
to be the first layer of t
or just simply like the root node of t
t2 the first two layers
p3 the first three layers so and so
forth
and then you know i get the t sub log s
cubed
that will be t itself all right think of
t
as being grown this way layer by layer
i'm gonna define a potential function
that assigns a score
a value to every tree in this sequence
t1 i'm going to assign in the score
t2 i'm going to assign it the score and
so on and so forth that this score is
between 0 and 1.
and the strategy is quite natural for
every
k let's say let's focus on this dk
i'm gonna have this proof this case
split either i'm already done
that tk itself is order or plus epsilon
close to f
and you know it's not too hard to argue
that if that's true then the subsequent
g
d k plus one t k plus two is going to
remain close to f
so i'm either already done or if i'm not
already done then i get a
nice drop in potential the the potential
of the next stream gk plus one
is gonna be smaller than the potential
of the current tree by quite a bit
epsilon squared over log s cubed
so if i'm if i'm able to prove this
dichotomy then
then the result follows since if my
potential function is
bounded between 0 and 1 and you know i
always drop by at least epsilon squared
over log sq
then certainly you know before that log
x cubed over x 1 squared i must
fall into case 1. i can only fall into
case 2 that many times
before i have to fall into case 1.
okay so i like to tell you about this
potential function
and you know tell you about this proof
okay the potential function is it
assigns
it takes in a tree and outputs zero one
and in words there's a noise sensitivity
of f
with respect to this 3t so we have seen
the definition of noise sensitivity of f
what does it mean to take the normal
sensitivity of f with respect to a tree
t
well it's quite natural it simply means
to take the noise sensitivity of the sub
functions defined by
t so i take the expectation over all
leaves of t
of the noise sensitivity of the sub
function of f at that leaf
and let's to get sort of comfortable
with this definition let me make
two super basic observations one is that
phi of the mp3
is simply the noise sensitivity of f
itself and there's a number between zero
and one
because it's you know the probability
that f of x differs from f of y
where y is a noisy copy of x so that's
uh observation one
and observation two is since i'm
thinking expectation of
something non-zero uh well something
non-negative uh the fee of any tree t
is at v0 for all trees t so
here i've i've with we've convinced
ourselves that v is indeed
uh the output is bounded between zero
and one
okay so
now let's get to uh analyzing the drop
in potential
when i go from tk to tk plus one my goal
in this slide is to convince you that
our potential function
defined in the previous slide syncs up
perfectly
with our splitting criteria which is to
split on the variable with the highest
noise influence
so they're sort of designed to sync up
perfectly with with each other so
in this slide i like to you know
formalize what i mean by that
okay and recall that tk plus 1 is
obtained
from tk by splitting every leaf
of tk according to the variable
with the highest noisy influence on the
relevant sub function
so let's okay let's look at the drop in
potential
of gk versus tk plus one the first
equality is just by definition the phi
of t
k is the noise sensitivity of f with
respect to g k
and c of t k plus one is noise
sensitivity of f
with respect to t k plus one and
how do we relate these two quantities
well here i'm taking expectation
of f with respect to g k so i take a
random path
down to a leaf and i report the noise
sensitivity of f
sub l and so how do we compare this
well this path l has a
the same path of course occurs in tk
plus one
now rather than you know
ending at the leaf it ends at a variable
x i
l which is a variable with the highest
noisy influence on f sub l
so how do we relate noise sensitivity of
f sub l with the noise sensitivity of
these two sub functions these are the
two subfunctions that contribute to this
quantity
so if we can do this we can relate this
then you know we we should be in good
shape
well this is the definition of noisy
influence
the noise sensitivity of s of l
this is what occurs on the left-hand
side is equal to the noisy influence of
the variable you query
plus average noise sensitivity of the
two induced
sub-functions right noisy influence is
defined to be
the drop in noise sensitivity when you
query
this variable so that's nice so this
you know with this so this is just a
bunch of equalities
we get the drop in potential can be
written in terms of noisy influences you
go through all the leaves of gk
and the drop in potential is exactly the
noise
influence of the variable that's queried
you know when you go to tk plus one
so as i alluded to this the goal of this
slide is just to convince you that our
split criterion syncs up perfectly with
our potential function
in fact our splitting criterion is
designed to greedily
drive down the potential function we
want to query the variable
of highest noisy influence it's the best
thing am i running out of time
you just turn the video on no i just
wanted to show to you that we're
listening
oh thanks thank you i appreciate that
okay good just out of curiosity how much
time do i have
you have a little bit less than 10
minutes like more
more six minutes seven minutes
perfect thank you so much okay good so
that's our potential
you know uh it syncs up perfectly with
our clean criteria in fact just like
it's very much inspired by real
heuristics which is to immediately drive
down some sort of potential function
and here we're really driving down noise
sensitivity
okay and you know this is sort of the
end of the technical
part of the talk so how do we show that
we drive down the potential
well thanks to the previous slide it
suffices to show that we drive
we recording variables of large noisy
influence
uh notion of importance so this is a key
lemma
that for this part of for the structural
result
it says the following if ff is up close
to a small decision tree size s
then i can lower down um the noisy
influence of the the variable with the
highest noise
uh the max overall i of the noisy
influence of
i on f is at least variance of f tilde
which i'll define in a second
minus opt divided by log s squared i'll
walk
walk through how we apply this grammar
in a second but for now let me just
annotate it a little bit f tilde is a
smoothened version of f
unfortunately due to time constraints i
do not have time to
formally define what i mean by smoother
but for for the
experts in the audience this is you know
what you get by applying like the noise
operator that have this
factor and noise operated f
and everything is sort of high level and
not super formal here here i'm hiding
the dependence on noise rate in this
inequality
noisy influence actually hides
well takes in a parameter delta and
which i
have not denoted and also this
inequality here also has a dependence on
this noise rate delta
and also you know actually the
smoothened version of that actually
depends on sort of like how much it's
moving in outline
which is also delta so this is informal
um but there's a general idea of of this
key lemma we need to show that
we always get a variable of large noisy
influence and hence we are always sort
of aggressively
driving down the potential function
so let me address uh i'm gonna i'd like
to talk us through how we apply this
lemma
and let me just understand something so
you're gonna apply the lemma to f pi yes
yes exactly and and so s is also going
down as you go down in the tree like f
pi
is represented by a smaller
so yeah so that's a little subtle well
yeah exactly so um first of all things
are tricky
because f itself is close to the size
that's entering three
but there's no guarantee that f pi is
like also close to a small decision tree
right you have to do this in expectation
write an expectation that's true so
that's one tricky thing that comes up
uh but well other than that you know
it's it takes work but you know we apply
this not only to f but all the f price
as we go along
and we have to track you know what's
your arg you don't you know in on
average
of all the ops is not fast so that's
good and you know
you have to now you're not dealing with
f tilde you're dealing with that high
tilde
and that's all that stuff but but the
variance is also going down
the variance of f pi or ftl pi exactly
so i'll come to that but so yeah okay
yeah but roughly speaking if the
variance is too low i'm already happy
yeah so that's this case but uh thanks
so i'll get to how we apply this lemma
in the next bullet but
now let me quickly mention it is a
variant of the os
i should have a footnote here sorry yeah
this is a
variant of the oss inequality from
analysis of boolean functions
named after the authors which itself
you can it's also you can think of it as
a variant of the
quality um so that's just one thing i
want to mention
and we sort of built quite heavily on
the techniques to get this
so as the title of the paper suggests
every decision tree has an influential
variable
well you can think of our lemma as
saying that every decision tree has a
variable of high noisy influence so it's
so
you know we built built on the
techniques in the paper
to get this lemma and so how do we apply
this lemma
well uh well when is the right hand side
well we're happy when the right hand
side is large because it gives us a
lower bond on a noisy influence
well if the variance of f tilde is at
least
up plus epsilon then the right hand side
is at least epsilon over log s
squared so that makes me happy uh what
this lambda is not so useful
if the variance of f tilde is at most or
plus epsilon
uh this takes a little bit of argument
because it's only a statement about f
tilde but you you go from here to saying
that f
itself also has variance in moles order
of plus epsilon which from then you can
then conclude that f is order f
or plus epsilon close to a constant
um so that's sort of like the proof
strategy uh
if you know f if i if i'm dealing with
an f
pi such that the variance of the tilde
version is small
then i'm sort of happy if not i get a
good drop in potential
well in which case i'm not so happy but
yeah
good uh well that's sort of the
technical
as yeah as i said i i i
i like to mostly skip the next part but
although
let me actually just remind you what our
reconstruction algorithm is and tell you
about like one
standalone challenge we had to overcome
and the team the the sort of like
the way we overcome it because i i think
that this the way we overcome it may be
of
independent interest so here's our
reconstruction algorithm
um it's been a while we are given query
access of f
it's promised to be close to a small
size decision tree we support queries
with distributed hypothesis t
we do not construct it in full but we're
able to sort of like
answer queries to it on the fly and we
are able to answer every query
quite efficiently quite a bit more
efficiently than the information
theoretic minimum required to learn a
good hypothesis
okay so that's our reconstruction
algorithm and it's
it's the the way it follows from our so
the
structural lemma that i just walked us
through is is a big component of it
but that itself doesn't quite give us
the reconstruction algorithm there's
still one challenge that came up
and i'd like to tell you about this
standalone challenge so i'm going to
skip a bunch of slides
oops
so here's the here's the standalone
challenge
well perhaps not surprisingly you like
to find a variable
with large noisy influence right it's
along the way so here's a standalone
task
given query access to f you know you can
interact with it
but using as few queries as possible i
like to report i
such that exactly as we expect well this
i is such that is the
coordinate with the highest noisy and f
right so this came up in getting the
reconstruction algorithm
and we'll like to do this with as soon
queries as possible
well one one challenge that comes up is
that f has n variables
and so the naive way to do this is to
estimate all
n noise influences it's not too hard to
see that this can be done to you know
you can estimate
every noisy influence using queries
efficiently
however there are n variables so if we
estimated all n noise influences and
outputted like the max that this seems
like it would give us omega
n very complexly whereas i promised you
log n or complexity so here's a lemma
that we had to prove it's not too hard
but i find it independently interesting
we give a query efficient way of
simultaneously estimating all
n1c influences so we are given query
access to f
we make one of the tau squared times log
n so the key thing here is the log n
dependence
and power is an accuracy parameter and
after this interaction with f
we report n things a to one to beta n
and we get it with high probability a to
i is a tau accurate
estimate of the noisy influence of imf
so with this you know this is the second
key part to our reconstruction algorithm
the first part being our structural
result and this
this lemma comes in as well and i do not
have time to tell you about the proof
but at the crux of the proof this is
like a the lambda itself gives like a
one over tau squared times log n
query um estimator the crux of the proof
is come up with like a two query
unbiased estimator for all n noise
influences
and with this two query thing you just
amplify and be inbound
okay so that's i hope i still have a few
minutes i'd like to wrap up with some
some ebony's or future work
okay so the first one is uh are there
any further applications of all
structural results well one thing
is that you know the quantitatively it
can be it could be improved
you know this this it'd be nice to
figure out whether we can improve this
it'll be nice to make this one time soft
but
beyond that it'll be nice to find
applications of the structural result
beyond what we've talked about in this
in this talk so as i alluded to briefly
this this was inspired by real world
decision tree learning heuristics
this the structural result and in this
talk we we have similar applications of
reconstruction and testing
these these decision trees come up
in other places as well so i wonder if
this structural result could be useful
for
for other things so that's one thing the
second thing
um is for understanding the relationship
between learning and
testing and reconstruction of decision
trees as i
mentioned at the start of the talk these
are generic algorithmic tasks
you can ask it for any function class
that you like and indeed people have
asked it for many function classes
but for the class of decision trees the
connections seem to be surprisingly rich
uh i only had a chance to touch on a few
of these surprising implications
in particular one thing i did not care
to talk about which which i really like
is this fact that testing decision trees
in some sense implied learning of
decision trees
so um which is not known for many of
these connections are not known or maybe
it's just
false for other classes but for decision
trees it seems like by leveraging the
specific structure of decision trees we
get a very nice
sort of like web of connections it's
much more to be understood
quantitative and quite quantitatively
and qualitatively
among these three tasks all very basic
and independently interesting and it's
nice that they have this connection
and finally let me just make a pitch for
for a question i i really like
which is to understand these like
practical decision tree learning
heuristics this is not related to
not directly related to the talk but
some of these
algorithms are used in practice that
sort of really just picks a good
variable and splits on it
it picks a good variable splits on it so
and so forth
can we give rigorous guarantees on on
the
on the quality of these algorithms what
are some of the limitations of these
heuristics so
the most important decision we make here
is to decide what to split on
basically that's the only decision you
make you know you really choose a good
thing to split on and keep going
so is there like a theory of of you know
this splitting criteria being better
than this so and so forth
and finally decision trees you know it's
a lot of algorithms in the real world
they do not grow just one decision tree
but they grow like 100 and they take the
majority vote or something like this or
they throw it into like a booster
boosting algorithm and these really work
very well in practice but
given that we don't really understand
how a single decision tree learning
algorithm works
we don't really have a very good
understanding of this random forest and
boost the decision tree algorithms
either
so as far as i know there's not been too
much theory work on
in this line except uh and
by now classic paper of prince and
mansour which is a very nice theory
paper on these like top-down decision
tree learning algorithms
and just sort of close with a quote from
them which says that it seems fair to
say that despite their other successes
the model
models of computational learning theory
have not yet provided a significant
insight into the apparent
empirical success of programs like c 4.5
and cart
and these are exactly sort of the
decision tree algorithms that back then
was
widely used in practice and today still
continuously widely used in practice
so that paper is very nice it took a big
step towards
rectifying this lack of understanding of
of these
these uh heuristics but still i i
believe that
the statement is still quite true today
and you know 30 years is a long time we
all know a lot more about the symmetries
now than we did 30 years ago so i think
it's a good time to sort of look at this
question again
i really like it okay thank you very
much great
thanks a lot liang so we are
uh very much out of time so
it's okay we should we should now take a
ten minutes break
uh before the last talk uh of the
session
so we have a ten minutes break and we'll
start again at
11 30 11 32.